hey guys merry and justin here at bandai
namco for TGS 2015 and we probably saw
one of the most amazing things I've ever
seen Star Wars related Justin I don't
know about the most amazing thing summer
was related but bandai namco has a
really cool arcade machine here and like
arcades are still alive and well in
japan and this is something like maybe
we'll see in the US but it's called the
Star Wars battle pot it's here behind us
and even though of me it's not on
hydraulics it gives you the sense of
being in these different ships and
different vehicles from the Star Wars
universe what you got to try out was
actually just one of the speeder bikes
from Endor yeah yeah I was on Endor it
was amazing how realistic it felt so the
screen actually wraps around you almost
like 180 degrees you really feel like
you're there and then you're on the
speeder bike which is got a
predetermined set path that it's going
to go but you also get a throttle stick
on your left and then you get your
attack on the right and you have two
different types attack there's just a
regular gun and then there's a missile
launcher and it feels so good to push
that throttle forward and get this huge
burst and speed and then you're going to
shooting at the enemies as they are in
your trajectory and then maybe hitting a
few missiles here and there it's not an
easy game though it's got its got a
little bit of difficulty depending on
which level you pick and even outside of
the traditional like we know where
there's going to be the run in indore
there's gonna be the Death Star trench
run there's gonna be the hot level one
of the fun ones that I tried out was an
alternate reality where you're playing
it's Darth Vader and you get to I shot
down han Solo and I was just like
destroying the rebels and it felt so
cool to be in his tie bomber and just
like flying around destroying all these
enemies and it gives you that sense of
like moving around like even though I
don't think it made a big difference i
was just like jerk that stick back in
first just to try to save myself to make
sure that i could get a lock on these
enemies it it gives you that really fun
exciting sense of being in those
vehicles definitely and it did have some
great surround sound so you could feel
the different noises of your jet engines
and people shooting at you from your
writer from your left you really got
that feeling and then in addition they
had a gust of wind that would hit your
face when you hit the throttle is ironic
because probably when you're in a ship
you didn't feel wind but I don't care
because it felt real
me and it really helps with that sense
especially on Endor which you actually
probably would feel that wind anyway so
we got that I was like this probably
isn't gonna fit but like know what
you're in the heat of the moments like
no just matter I could have the win in
my face with a pilot is next week it was
incredibly vivid and real and if there's
anything that I want to experience I
want to be on a speeder bike and Endor
and that really did give me that amazing
sense of exhilaration and satisfaction
in the Star Wars universe it was awesome
I I don't know if the game like this
would ever come to the US but they're
definitely japanese arcades all across
the world when you get the chance I
think this is a really fun one to try
out yeah there's no doubt that this
would be a very expensive addition to
your home collection fine individually
but i recommend you trying it out there
was one of the coolest things I've seen
so far and for everything else tgs
related be sure to head to gamespot com
you